[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Бессарабія,
Шабо]
Жити – це не тільки працювати.
Не потрібно думати тільки про гроші.
Потрібне щастя та насолода життям.
[Кристоф де Лакарен
Винороб]
Перші люди, що посадили тут виноград, були греки.
2500 років тому.
Я тут займаюсь рожевим вином
і рожевим шампанським.
Тут земля така, внизу – глина.
Коли спекотно – авторегуляція для води.
Ця територія – чудова.
Я приїхав до України в жовтні 2002 року.
І я щасливий бути тут,
якби так не було – тікав би звідси.
Я працював на львівській фабриці косметики
як парфюмер півтора року.
У Львові – європейські люди.
Це точно.
Європейські люди культурно та архітектурно.
Київ. Я не знаю, що таке Київ,
бо не люблю це місто.
Я тільки виїжджав туди на зустрічі
й одразу повертався.
Донбас. Раніше я працював багато з ними
і в мене багато друзів звідти.
Але це ще інші [люди].
Це шахти, це як Північна Франція,
такі строгі, рівні люди.
Й Одеса. 21 грудня 2002 року вперше я поїхав туди.
І коли я побачив таке місто,
сказав: «Вау! Оце хороше місто».
На той момент я працював
чотири дні на тиждень у Львові.
І три дні я насолоджувався життям в Одесі.
Якоїсь неділі я поїхав до Шабо
через Дністровський лиман.
Я побачив цю територію й землю
і подумав: «Це ж чудово!»
Така земля,
такий клімат, такий вітер,
таке повітря, свіже натуральне, чисте.
І все.
Коли ти хочеш – тобі потрібно.
Я завжди кажу своїм людям:
«Ти хочеш – зможеш!»
Бо вони завжди кажуть:
«А це я не можу».
А я кажу: «Хочеш – зможеш.
Або ти не хочеш».
Коли я побачив, що тут радгосп хоче викорчувати
виноградник, сказав їм «стоп». І забрав його.
Я їздив сюди, щоб організувати
перше органічно чисте виробництво.
Бо на той момент тут не було жодного фермера,
що займався екологічно  чистим виробництвом.
Жодного.
Виноградник я купив у колгоспу. 130 гектарів.
Я люблю тварин.
Бо територія без тварин – це не життя.
І я також люблю справжній продукт.
Тому купив курей.
Кури дають яйця.
Наші діти, коли були маленькими –
завжди мали змогу їсти натуральні яйця.
Кози – це добре,
бо є справжнє хороше молоко
з великим вмістом кальцію.
М’ясо – теж саме, розумієте?
І ще в нас є коні,
бо я їх дуже люблю. І все.
І собаки. Я теж люблю дуже собак.
Це старий глиняний будинок
швейцарських колоністів.
Тільки гаражі – з радянського періоду.
Люди збирають виноград на полі,
далі – дробилка.
Відділити гілочки.
Далі сік.
Сік стоїть тут одну ніч,
поки впаде перший осад.
Далі, наступний день – перекачуємо.
Сік починає бродити.
І коли закінчується бродіння – в другий зал.
І далі перекачати, своє вино я не фільтрую.
Оці великі об’єми я організував для одного вина
за старим бургундським рецептом.
Тут виноградний сік починає бродити
всередині кожної ягоди.
А оцей квадратний – для ніг,
але це тільки раз у рік, перша неділя жовтня.
І тільки для жінок, бо вони займаються педикюром.
Тут вино перекачується, розливається,
закривається у пляшки, клеються етикетки.
Далі коробки і доставка майже по всій Україні.
У будь-якій країні світу є проблеми.
На жаль, люди в селі – іншої культури.
Культура радгоспу – без крадіжок жити не можна.
Це історія, це 1930-ті роки, розкуркулення.
Людям на той момент не було чого їсти.
А як можна тоді жити? Тільки з крадіжок.
Коли в країні війна – це ситуація катастрофічна,
це нестабільність.
Як можна думати про перспективи,
як можна організувати, наприклад, бізнес-план?
На 3, на 5 років.
Не можна, люди думають про сьогодні.
А що ти можеш сьогодні?
Заробляй трішки там і кради трішки отам.
Я скажу вам правду:
думав тікати з України в грудні 2013 року,
коли почалися заворушення.
Тому що я відчував, що відбувається
щось дуже нехороше для країни.
І я почав питати у всіх моїх українських друзів,
що вони думають про ці мої відчуття.
Вони сказали: «Ні, Лакарен, ні! Все буде добре».
І ми сподіваємось, що за якийсь час так буде.
Не завтра, бо завтра – це неможливо.
Але через декілька років в Україні стане краще.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Андрій Рогозін]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Tik Tu, Blooms Corda]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]